good afternoon everyone and welcome to
the Friday app review my name is reto
Meier I'm joined by Fred Chung
and we're gonna take a look at some apps
today so we asked you guys for some
suggestions for recipe apps and you did
not give us any which means one of two
things either you guys don't like recipe
apps or there aren't any recipe apps
it's such an overwhelming crowd yes
this is you just couldn't pick from
among the very many good ones too many
huh apparently so so we're going to do
this week in stairs have a look at some
of our favorites so Fred's got a couple
of food-related apps which ones are you
gonna take a look at today yeah we're
gonna have a look at my food and big
oven excellent and I well the reason I
was asking you guys for recipe apps was
because I didn't know of any good ones
so rather than spend time looking at
apps I've never looked at before I'm
gonna take a look at some of my favorite
apps in terms of apps that I use a lot
of and that series guide IMDB and if we
get time I'm gonna take a look at TripIt
as well now before we get started I just
want to clarify a little bit about what
we're trying to achieve here at the
Friday app review so unlike a lot of the
review shows that you may have seen
we're not really focused on sort of
giving a fair and balanced evaluation of
what are some great apps that we think
you guys should be installing we're part
of a developer relations team here at
Android so our focus is really on trying
to help developers build better apps and
so to do that whenever we look at these
apps we're really trying to dissect them
take them apart see what they're doing
right see what they're doing wrong and
really try and create a learning
experience so that other app developers
can learn from the and the mistakes and
the successes of these other apps so
really the app of you doesn't make a lot
of sense as a title so we're actually
going to change the name of our show
live on air and so from this point
onwards we are going to become a Friday
app clinic now in order to in order to
maintain that new branding I have some
props so I'm going to disappear off
camera and get my props come back soon
don't panic
and Daniel if our producer off-camera
can also switch our our title so that we
can become me the further up clinic we
have double with the size of our
production team that's you're at twice
as many producers yes one moment that's
right we have all the time in the world
all right sir
I have my hour I haven't 45 minutes and
we should get this sorted out all
right sir
we have our doctor droids I was my lab
coat where's mine hey that's a bring
your own it's yeah I mean come on man
this is that's what that box was for
absolutely yeah you are you need to
order your own equipment just pretend
this is this is a wife okay we should
have one at least a gray shirt so we can
you know make the next time maybe that's
right that's right let's knock this up
on Fred here as well so this is his
first clinic sir so I'll be the I can be
the official clinician and Fred can
continue to read to be a reviewer so
let's go service I look at one of one of
your apps let's start with old-style
yeah I decided to stick to something
that are related to recipe and both of
these apps as I mentioned earlier my
food and big oven if we could a switch
to the tablet please both of these apps
try to tackle the problem where you're
trying to figure out what what's for
dinner and then you have to figure out
what what what kind of dishes you would
like to get and after the preparation
stage you can translating the types of
ingredients into some sort of shopping
list and these two apps try to solve
this problem and they try to do it a
little bit differently and that's when
we have a look at my food so as soon as
this app is launched is pretty
self-explanatory it's got three
high-level items menu items that you can
pick
shopping list recipes and meal planner
and all these are their prominently
displayed which is nice which makes it
very easy for users to comprehend so you
you would go into recipe first but
before going diving into the content of
recipe I like to highlight that you know
when I tap on any of these targets
there's no touch feedback hmm so I would
like what we've been asking developers
to do you know when you come with
graphics icons be sure to have DIF have
them represented in different states to
represent the natural state focused
stage and press states so that's really
important particularly for accessibility
so if you want blind users to be able to
use your app or even just people who are
using you know accessibility type
features to make it more easy and then
having those touch targets selectors is
really important right and before I go
into any of these let's have a quick
look at the menu so there's help
settings the items that the usual
suspects basically yeah things that you
would expect to sit under the overflow
menu absolutely
I'm gonna point out as well here that
you know looking at this main screen
here as well you can see that we've
actually got an action bar which is
which is good but in this case I think
actually would make a lot of sense to
have an action bar which was perhaps
translucent because you've kind of got
this whole screen effect here where it's
it's sort of this immersive thing
completely custom controls the action
bar almost looks a little bit sort of
plunked on top so perhaps changing the
color of your action bar to match the
background or have a translucent action
bar will be a solution yeah let's have a
look at the recipe screens as you can
see in this drop-down box there are
different types of occasions like
starter sides you know whatever and
there are different categories that you
can choose from and it pre-populated
with a bunch of delicious absolutely and
you can swipe through the selection of
dishes so these are the top-level recipe
items
what you can do is to look at the
various ingredients and the steps
involved in the preparation in the
preparation of the dish what I would
suggest is that when you have a tablet
right there are the most probable use
cases someone using your app in a
kitchen I might be sitting 3 to 4 feet
away from the tablet to the font size
and as it stands it's kind of a little
bit too small right yeah it is it's a
little on time in reading the text
exactly what you want to really have is
so that you can set up a tablet on your
kitchen bench probably a little further
away from the food and as you know
sources of heat and then then you would
want otherwise and so you really want to
be able to see this text from a good
sort of five to ten feet away assuming
you have a bigger kitchen than me
overflow menu I wish they had an option
where he can increase the font size but
it at least I can't find it hmm from
here and what's interesting is that for
each step you can go in and edit it
sometimes that's not you like to deviate
absolutely yeah there's no recipe I use
that I haven't modified slightly you
know what else would be really nice here
I don't know if there's any support for
it but to have the ability to add
pictures for each step I find that's
really useful if it looks the way it's
supposed to have I've done things the
right way like when they say Brown at
how Brown is it's supposed to be those
sorts of things would be really nice so
a picture of the finished product and
also a picture of each step that's a
great suggestion
now you can capture it for motivation
absolutely well this is what I would do
right I would I would do the recipe and
I would take a photo of each step so
that I was able to see the process of
going through and potentially even the
ability to add a video you know if I
record the whole thing of how it all
went
we've got Roman grain so what do you
think Roman if you had a chance to have
a look at this up with youth what are
your thoughts from a UI perspective so I
haven't had a chance to take a full look
but just from looking at what's we guys
are showing now kind of the same common
problems that we see everywhere are
showing up in this app and they're not
really problems I mean it's just you
know I think probably the lack of a
tablet optimized UI and we're in some
tablet
one thing I wanted to mention was just
on the very home screen I guess the top
level screen that had that kind of
massive dashboard um I just wanted to
make a shout out for for I guess against
dashboards and using dashboards
especially on tablets
there are lots and lots of different
ways you can you know show show kind of
a top level screen and some of those
ways are actually listed in are the
design guidelines under the app
structure pattern so I definitely
recommend taking a look there to see how
you can get away from a dashboard you
don't necessarily have to you know
completely remove the dashboard but one
thing you could do is potentially kind
of include content right there so when
you're showing the the big icons or the
big buttons to get into a section show
preview over the content that you're
about to see when you tap into the
section so just one of the features
alright some pictures and all the dishes
that you're trying to prepare that's
great
so let's let's go back to recipes and as
I was testing this application I tried
to add a new dish yeah at first I
thought okay this at button represented
but it in said that's an easy recipe
right right but instead what I was
looking for is hidden in the overflow
menu oh I say new recipes so I think it
would be great you know to expose this
feature on the action bar of their space
yeah definitely and I think there is
plenty of space on the action bar for
that add recipe seems like it would be
one of the main features I wouldn't want
to do within an app notice absolutely
and let's have a quick look at shopping
list so what you can have various
shopping this associated with the
recipes that we looked at so let's say
you've decided on what to cook for
dinner then you can quickly trance
transfer the list of items into your
shopping list I think it it's a good use
case where at home the user might be
using a tablet to come up with the list
of recipes and then based on the recipe
the list of recipes you come up with a
shopping list and then if you support
something like syncing with the cloud
when you take out
you have Android device out you can have
the shopping list with you at the
grocery store we can mark off various
items do you know if this has the
ability to sync like are you signing in
at any point if I have my tablet which
lives in my kitchen or at least in my
living room in kitchen to be able to do
recipes and I sync that up with my phone
so I have my shingle suite Manero was
but I can't recall but if assuming it
does I think it would be a good use case
mmm definitely yeah yes so that would be
that would be my wish list I think for
me did you just go ahead and start using
this would be features lots of pictures
food you know eating and preparing food
a big part of that is as visual so being
able to see what the cauliflower cheese
soup looks like is going to make it much
more likely for me to actually you know
create it certainly whenever I'm using
cookbooks and recipes seeing that
picture of what it's going to end up
like is it a big thing for me and I also
say that you know for this kind of apps
where initially there's a bunch of data
entry hmm you might want to think of
ways to make it easier for developed for
users right because I imagine if it
becomes too cumbersome to enter a lot of
text that you experience a lot of
drop-offs so you may think of ways to
you know maybe support up scanning for
barcodes and stuff like that that
wouldn't make it a lot easier for
different for users absolutely or
alternatively you can have a lot more
pre-populated items and what people use
just to pick and choose from an existing
list that would be that will make the
user experience better yeah in fact you
know thinking is through actually the
way I would start to use this so right
now at home I have this big folder with
recipes which I've pulled out of
newspapers and photocopied from people
and printed out emails and so I'm
probably not going to want to enter all
of that in straightaway so my first step
would just be to photograph each one
just give it a title and then scan in
that the picture and then I can always
go through and actually sort of populate
the field separately later we're getting
the wrap we have 39 35 seconds left
today and we have a new probably haven't
got our gong to so we want to run out
the time just so we can have the Gong go
it's very important
I don't think we should actually just
wait 22 seconds it goes off but let's
say so so we've got the categories here
we've got everything else yeah it's
actually looking pretty good one on you
why don't you going us out to eat all
right no I really like that that was all
along okay I mean all in all it's a
great start and it looks like they
developed the development team is it's a
pretty small team so obviously so you
guys are watching if you hear about this
then do reach out to us and we'll try
and help to give you that extra feedback
to help really make this into our go-to
recipe yeah definitely now I want to cut
Fred off here but I didn't really think
this through because I haven't had lunch
and looking at recipes is making me
hungry so let's let's switch across and
have a look at one of these other apps
sure if I work for you all right let's
restart app time I would trying to be
able to allow interest of time when do
we want to look at I would have a look
at series guide this is an act by used
quite a lot of and I think I think was
actually Roman who were who put me on to
this so you were a series guide a user
as well Roman I am I absolutely am I
think this app is one of my favorites
for for tracking episodes and TV shows
so yeah it's a look at the tablet view
and so one so these are some of my
favorite app so I'm gonna be
particularly not harsh but I'm gonna
have a pretty high bar for some of the
comments that I have here for them and
so one of the big kicks that I'm on at
the moment is trying to create apps that
present a magical experience so apps
that you're not really thinking about
them running on a phone you're not
thinking about the internet connection
you're not thinking about anything other
than the functionality that they provide
so that's kind of the basis around which
I'm going to be providing some of this
feedback so if you look on the getting
started guide right here we're asked to
choose our primary content language we
have the ability to connect to a social
network associated with it and an option
to send develop a usage statistics and
this is all fair enough but the problem
with it is that straight away I open the
app and I'm presented with all of these
all of this text all these choices so
generally speaking I find it much better
if you just load up the app and it
straightaway dumps you into whatever it
is that the app is supposed to do so I
would suggest to the developers here too
actually see if you can remove all of
this on startup so that you're just able
to so you're just able to get straight
into the gear a little concern but what
I'm hearing over my shoulder that will
will continue um the other thing I want
to mention is um you know when you when
you just get into a nap usually you're
presented or in apps that are just list
views or or just you know where the
primary content pane is basically empty
because you haven't done anything in the
app yet there's no need to present a
dialog just present any sort of
introductory material like stuff that
you do happens here right in line
there's there's a big opportunity to use
the kind of the empty view you know when
your ListView has no items in it use the
empty view to be you know to be more
visual and do so right in line in the
content sort of thing about if you're
going to do it at all
yeah I totally agree in fact if we
dismiss this here we get exactly that we
get this massive pain of emptiness which
just says no shows here and so now what
we're supposed to do is start adding in
the shows that we are interested in
watching and you do that by hitting the
plus button which makes total sense and
then we can start searching for shows
now what you'll also notice it here
you've got this trending tab which shows
you a bunch of shows which other people
have been looking for now there's a
bunch of these that I actually do want
to track now I don't know what do you
think Roman for me I would love to see
basically that intro screen being all of
the trending training shows which I can
then just go in and add right off the
bat so that's sort of the way you get
started is by seeing a whole bunch of
suggestions based on what other people
have been adding and had that ability to
just go yeah Breaking Bad Plus Game of
Thrones applause next applause
absolutely and then cos straightaway you
understand what it is that the what the
show is offering so again here we have
kind of this this big dialog explaining
what the show is giving us the synopsis
and the ability to add now that's useful
and I would I would certainly like to
have that as a plus but you know in the
instance here I'd even more so prefer
just a bunch of plus buttons along this
outer edge so that I can just say well I
know what Breaking Bad is I've been
watching it for the past you know five
years so I just want to add it without
having yet read about pop-up a little
bit like this
continued variance right exactly thank
ya the other thing is that I mean the
way this is listed the way shows are
listed in this app is they're basically
listed as a list right it's a vertical
list of things where as was really kind
of media friendly stuff like content I
guess media rich content presenting
something the grid is generally just
better you know it leaves you more space
to show nice big photos even like
overlay the titles over the photos so
that everything almost every pixel on
the screen is covered by content that's
that's generally better than presenting
just a list of like thumbnail on the
left and smaller one day of defeat that
they're getting from if they have have
bigger assets they do they absolutely do
in fact it's one of the strengths of
this app you do take advantage of it so
let's let's go back to to the main menu
so I've added a bunch of shows and you
can see straight away that they're
already presenting something better here
so once you go to the shows that you've
already included you get the you know
that grid view which Roman was talking
about but even here I'd say like there's
an opportunity here to use that space
more to use bigger assets so this
becomes a really visual experience you
know having the the images associated
with these shows is I think a really
powerful thing and so I would you know I
would consider making that a much bigger
part of each grid item very much along
the lines of what Roman was suggesting
so the point here is is that it's
telling us when or when our next episode
of all of these shows are coming up so
we have a bunch of options that we can
choose to so if you go into settings we
have sort of this wall of settings which
allow us to do things like you know only
show episodes which have already been on
the for which reduces my list which
makes me sad home but you can see
exactly what's coming and then you can
go into each of the show's game Thrones
and then you get all the details so the
directors guest stars
what episodes are on or coming and you
can see here in the background you've
rather got the big graphic right yeah
not coming across as well for that one
so what does a check-in do so check-in I
think if you're logged in to tracked or
simply not it lets you basically have
that social aspect where you're checking
into the show so if you're watching it
you check in as part of that have you
actually said about this no I don't use
the check in as much I know this is kind
of a growing more popular interaction
you know to actually check into shows as
they come on but am I ever used in
myself it is a very popular thing with
services like get glue and I believe
track this one yes I guess it's around
that whole second screen experience idea
way sort of socializing while you're
watching TV I struggle with it because I
very seldom watch TV live I'm always
time shifting it and watching it at
least an hour so later yeah the Olympics
yeah yeah well the Olympics it's not by
choice but this is not the forum for me
to rant because I don't have enough time
to explain exactly how I feel about the
NBC coverage I'll be just pointing out
that similarity so yeah yeah the other
thing which I have to say about this app
so like I say Roman suggested this to me
and I you know I use it a lot now but
one of the things I struggled with when
I first started the app is that it
wasn't immediately obvious to me how
everything worked so the plus icon being
ads show you know it wasn't immediately
obvious to me that that's what I was
going to do you know I didn't
necessarily understand the workflow and
so I think that's something which would
be really great to be simplified and
better explained and I think sort of
giving me that list of suggestions right
off the bat is going to help but sort of
sure helped me through the workflow make
it more obvious what I need to do at
each point and that will make it easier
for me to use all the features and in
the action body have a mix of tacks and
icons for any action items so maybe they
can go this so this is actually a
combined activity with a clock icon in
this search I yeah it does have the time
in little vertical separators actually
this is missing there is a missing
vertical separator between plus and
activity which is really confusing right
so it looks like it's the same thing
yeah it wasn't apparent to me that the
clock icon actually represent it's tied
to the activity hmmm tax search okay so
it's the right search icon so I mean
generally speaking they've done things
well but I'd also be really cautious
about things like your settings menu
where there are a lot of things here
you know advance and everything else you
may consider so this is actually using
the old preference activities rather
than the newer preference fragments so
there are a few options that you have
here to actually separate things into
categories and make it a little bit
easier to dissect so I'd want to have
things like advanced and more almost
often a separate category so it's not
sort of confusing the rest of it because
this is a little bit intimidating you've
been using a longer than I have Raymond
do you have any particular suggestions
that you'd like to point out about what
they do well or what they could do a
little bit better yeah I think I mean
then before I think when this tab just
came out it was using the default
payment and you know a lot of my
comments are visual so this would be
it's a visual feedback but before I
guess a couple months ago this app was
using default stock holo theme so
everything was kind of hollow blue and
everything and that was it was good I
think that you know obviously you do
want to modify you want to brand it a
little bit in this case I feel like the
branding is you know kind of that neon
purple hmm it doesn't really mesh all
that well with the rest of the holo UI
the holo style and so for example all
the window backgrounds are using the
default kind of hollow gradient from
dark from I guess black to like a dark
gray and then the non purple on top of
that doesn't seem to be in mesh well so
what I would do is I would probably go
through and and clean up some of the UI
I feel like there's some parts that are
really remnants of the default holo
style I'm sorry just make sure to kind
of either customize more dock and
branded kind of custom UI isn't as great
as it could be it's definitely better
than a lot of the other apps that we've
seen but that could be improved another
thing is this is very specific but when
you get into an episode of a show
there's actions at the top right like
search and favor and share and there's
actions like right in the middle of the
screen mm-hmm
yeah we're checking etc yeah I find that
a little strange and I think this kind
of violates one of the core rules of
putting things near the corners near the
edges it's a little easier to find a
little easier to discover unless I mean
unless the inline actions are really
obvious or in this case I feel like
they're very
under the content so one thing that I do
really often is you know Marcus shale
has watched and I feel like it's kind of
buried in a sea of text so that's one
thing that I would try to do you do have
actions that are in line make sure that
they're more visible that they're more
prominent that they stand out you know
apart from the content that surrounds it
because otherwise you know it may not be
obvious maybe difficult to locate yeah
totally agree and I think for a lot of
those would make sense to just have them
in the action bar because as you say
they kind of primary actions you know
having Watchers show so our Gong has
gone off so we're gonna have to move on
but I think that's some some interesting
advice I think the key things here is
that you know visual visually I think
they could do a lot more with what
they've got more images more grades more
density of color and imagery and and
similarly as well I think just to give a
couple of examples from what Roman was
saying and hopefully he'll agree I think
in terms of customized branding if you
have a look at an app like geekbeat does
a really good job of that they have
their own custom color schemes which is
throughout the entire app and it's
consistent and tasks tasks and tasks
free are a good example of which you are
actually using and paradigms
anyway with it actually something about
about it turns out there will lead you
to my quest and responded really quickly
to that that sounds like maybe it should
have been an option rather it sounds
like something that's actually brings up
a really interesting point particularly
if you're creating an app which is quite
popular it's going to be impossible to
satisfy all of your users and so like me
and Fred can sit here and have exactly
the opposite opinions about the same app
and certainly once you get more than a
couple of thousand downloads you're
going to have the same problem so one
thing you can do there is use analytics
a lot to figure out how people are
actually using your app and and so you
can do things like Institute options
where you have you know show images
don't show images and then find out
which people are using more and try and
build your user interface around that so
definitely something you want to
consider is you know before doing those
radical changes is to think about how
people are using the app and give them
the option to pick one or the other
before deciding which is the the best
approach right or if you have resources
and you know think about doing things
like a bee testing epsilen users react
to better so that that's great I mean
and also it's good to see that you are
reacting to use a comma dentist yeah
absolutely absolutely
cool all right so put your your next app
the next the next tab is called
big oven it's like I said before it's a
another app that consists of a lot of
recipes where it tries to gives you some
ideas on what for what's for dinner
what's for lunch and stuff like that and
you are able to identify the items and
create shopping lists based on the
recipes yes so I want to put them in a
tablet to layout what about this layout
to paying layout with a big logo here
what's what stands out initially is that
I see two search engines here so you
have a duplication of features on a very
same screen so you can think of you know
maybe maybe
you know eliminating one and maybe this
there's a specific reason why you
decided to include both it's not but it
feels duplicate duplicate it features so
so let's do a search on something it's
favorite recipe something that has to do
with beef beef you're the real developer
if you were a real Android developer
with being bacon there you go so it
shows you whoa a bunch of pictures so
these are user-generated content with
star ratings and you can let's say go
pick one beef chili with beans loading
recipes latency it's gonna say like if
we just drop back once this is a really
good example of an app which is using
that visual nough stew really draw you
in so you've just got this warm beef
which could be quite intimidating but in
this case it's just making me really
hungry if they do notice that it tends
to be a little bit slow in terms of
particularly this loading more recipe so
bringing the images in here slowly
that's that's reasonable although it
feels like based on the speed here it
feels like we're pulling down images
much bigger than the thumbnails being
displayed so if you're pulling them down
from a server and then shrinking them
try and have those shrunken assets on
the server so you're just pulling down
as little as possible and things like
this the loading more recipes try and
precache a little more aggressively so
you should have at least sort of a
Scrolls worth of data queued up so that
you don't feeling that that lag or when
you go back and this is kind of
unacceptable you really need to find
ways to cache your images all right you
will memorize ins likely still have to
dump them out of your out of your cache
in terms of your memory cache and
display them but it shouldn't take this
long to put them back in yeah if you
want to look for specific technical tips
on how to do it we we have a training
class and on Android training that
specifically talks about loading bitmaps
and caching and stuff like that we're
actually uh I think Adam Koch from our
team is planning some updates to that
another thing I want to point out is
that in the Google i/o application which
is now open source a bunch of new stuff
related to image caching is there as
well so you could
you know rip stuff right out of there
and I believe we're updating the enjoy
training article on that as well
awesome all right let's get back into
the bay from Chile with Baynes see that
the loading latency you know I think
it's a little slow right and that's when
I was when I was talking beforehand
about creating magical apps that's a big
part of it for me like every time you
see the loading dialog or a blank thing
which needs to be populated or fill up
that kind of breaks the magic it ruins
that suspension of disbelief and you
remember that oh this app needs to
connect to an Internet source and pull
down this data and pop your little this
view and I don't want to be made aware
of any of that I just kind of wanted to
magically happen as though this was some
crazy magic box with the future which
had every recipe in the world somehow
contained within it this looks nice the
UI here is definitely it's pretty clean
hmm yeah well I'd like to repeat the
comment the feedback that we can have
bigger text bigger 10x but I think this
particular app there's an option where
you can increase the font size which is
great and there are different tabs like
recipe reviews and photos excellent of
various yeah the latency I don't know
what's going on here we fast Network
yeah you definitely want to be
downloading this photos I rather suspect
that the photos are bigger than they
need to be and so you're pulling and I
noticed also that they all came in at
once here so again it's the same sort of
ideas of making sure you download more
than you you know download progressively
and and and make sure that you're
optimizing those dollars to pull down as
little as you need now if you come in
here make a comment here why of course
there is one thing I wanted to mention
it and this is just happening over and
over again I feel like every app we look
at on the tablet has this issue so white
space there there's just it's it's a
much better use of white space than
there are lots of the other apps you've
seen but still you know could be
improved and like you guys mentioned
you're increasing font sizes things like
that will help one trick that I find
useful when trying to optimize my white
space is to take a screenshot of my app
as it is and start shrinking it down
gradually shrink it down so about like
25% even 10% of its original size and
look at that right if you can still pick
out your whites
H from the text and if it's but if it
doesn't look even if it doesn't seem
like there's kind of a good natural
balance and in the the negative space
and the actual you know text and content
then you probably have a whitespace
problem so you know try to think of how
you can better fill out the white space
but don't tack in text into the white
space white space is still important but
make sure that it's balanced right so
that's just one trick you know shrink it
down and see if if there's something
that seems wrong in that shrunken
version so I had a question actually
related to that so if you if you have a
look at this you know this main search
results page where you have all of these
things so you know I like that there's
lots of images there and then we do
still have those gaps between now I know
that one of the UI trends that I've seen
a lot of lately is basically removing
all of those borders and having you know
basically zero margins between images
and while off pictures yeah is that
something you think would work well here
yeah I think that can definitely work
well in a lot of cases in this case
since the background is white I
personally find that having this kind of
zero pixel border like text overlaid on
top of images works really well
if the rest of the background I guess
the theme of the app is hollow dark or
just a darker theme otherwise the white
will really stand out
I'm essentially one thing that this time
I want to consider doing is trying that
you know trying to that wall of images
with very little space in between and
having the text overlaid on top of the
images but then try to switch the themes
that the lesson gain is not so bright
the contrast will be way too high if you
have that kind of all of images and
that's the other thing I was gonna
suggest as well like as as Fred pointed
out of I'm not sure if we can sort of
empty the screen so this is this is how
we get to when we open up the app now
again the whole point of a recipe app is
to make me hungry make me want to cook
stuff so it seems to me like this would
be a great opportunity to put something
here in this big empty space right from
the beginning like the most popular apps
or sorry most popular recipes or the you
know your favorite recipes or featured
recipes random recipes basically
anything because you have a random
recipe I don't know why don't you just
default it exactly ohno-san
actually
big picture yeah you know have a recipe
we'll have like a bunch of random
recipes but something which is going to
inspire you so that as soon as you open
this up you're like oh yeah actually
that looks like something I might like
to create it looks like almost like
within zero clicks right assume you get
featured and on Google Play you install
the app and you press the Open button
without doing anything else the user
should think wow I'm definitely keeping
this out exactly exactly right and and
you know recently maybe recent rate is
is is perfect yes so this is this is
what I would start with so these are the
recipes that most people have been
raving about if I opened the app
straight you know was featured on google
player hit install open boom and this is
what I saw suddenly I have much more
incentives than just from seeing this
big logo I can be like oh there's
earlier both look phenomenal you know
and straight away it's like oh you know
I don't need much for that it's got
cream cheese and re O's I'm pretty much
already sold and then straightaway your
system you know scrolling through things
and again getting really hungry which is
again why we want to make sure that you
you know you don't have this long load
time of each recipe clicking in cuz I
just want to be able to scroll through
this list and see anything which looks
awesome and be like oh wow I totally
need to make skewered honey balsamic
vinegar can Babs I need to stop that's
true the inconsistency there is is
definitely an issue they sort of have
the default blue line here and with the
red thread underneath the red line is
probably their brand and that yeah you
can definitely mmm yeah exactly I mean
given that you do kind of have this
strong color branding you may want to
consider using you know changing the
color of your action bar to match
through the rest of your color branding
and that's definitely something you can
do but I'm intrigued by Romans idea of
switching the the whole sort of theme
around to something darker and then
emphasizing the images more I'd also
point out that the actual text style
that they're using here is is a Surrey
front which works really well if you're
you know reading a book or something
like that but it doesn't work
as well on computer screens and
particularly when you're reading it from
a distance
so you'll notice most presentations tend
to use a sensory font like an Arial or a
Helvetica or something like that and
again with this app you may be browsing
it sitting down on your couch but you're
going to be using it in the kitchen on a
stand and again from a distance and so
again it's great that they let you bump
up the tech size I would probably prefer
here either an option or just a default
to be a sensory
one of the other things I want to
mention around Fonz's and and this is
kind of unfortunate we just I guess I
don't know if we just didn't have time
where we didn't plan on it but the new
font of Android the new typeface is
Roboto obviously and there's no serif
version of Roboto though so basically a
lot of the improvements a lot of the
kind of core image and and a you know
design philosophy of Android is around
the typography so you're missing a lot
of that by using droid serif having said
that I mean there's also Roboto thin and
Roboto light when you have text that's
larger let's say like in the 30s or the
40s PS Roboto light can really give it a
like a sense of class or elegance so
coupled with increasing the font sizes
you may want to consider using the
different weights of Roboto and and
there are several actually as of
jellybean we bundle very very many
weights of Roboto so you have more
options or you could just bundle the
TTFN directly okay standing cool alright
so that was out Gong in the background
so we're ready to move on to our next
step which is one of my so trip it's
kind of hard to demo without having some
troops in there we've only got a few
minutes so let's have a look at at IMDb
instead so you know based on the two
outs that I've looked at today you can
get a fair idea of how I enjoy to spend
some of my spare time but I'm a big fan
at the IMDB app so this is a great
example of an app which uses it's very
much its own custom branding so this
doesn't look like holo but it doesn't
not look like it either but it
definitely looks like IMDB we have this
consistent sort of gray gradient
branding with their quite distinctive
IMDB gold logo and again you know if we
look at what we've been talking about so
far with today's apps with
this up and straightaway I'm presented
with a wall of the images so I've got
video front and center and a scrolling
marquee I've got you know another
scrolling marquee down here awesome
looking movie posters coming soon it's
the same so this is a you know basically
it's it's full of imagery and that I
think it makes for a really compelling
experience because straightaway you've
got things to look at you've got things
just scroll you've got things to browse
so overall I quite like that it's not a
standard action bar because it's too
high to be a standard action bar and
they've done some kind of interesting
things here like this overflow menu is
clearly not a default the standard
overflow menu or even a standard pop-up
menu which a lot of people use to sort
of simulate that effect and so I don't
know to me it it almost works in that
it's got the branding it's got the grey
and the gold which is obviously the the
theme they're going throughout but the
weird rounded corners and the drop
shadow kind of strikes me as being a
little off like this is the first time
where I click something on the app and
suddenly it doesn't quite feel like a
native app anymore what do you think
room yeah I do want to call out like you
said the drop shadows the also some of
the great names like the title bar
rather the fake action bar has this kind
of start great one of the things we
generally recommend this is not like a
you must not use gradients on Android or
anything but we definitely recommend
using fewer visual effects things like
drop shadows things like gradients
things like glosses they they kind of
clash would be the minimalistic cleaner
style of Paulo and you know when a user
gets their Galaxy Nexus or one of their
ICS devices they're kind of presented
with somewhat minimal UI apps right how
does that give you content and minimize
the number of pixels that are dedicated
purely to aesthetics of the chrome of
the of the surrounding elements of the
app so definitely minimizing that and
using kind of some of the simpler
minimal styles would make more sense I
think and then definitely using the kind
of
stocke action bar and tweaking the
styles like you can make that if you
absolutely need that part of you taller
you can sweep that using styles you
don't have to reimplementation but in
fact that's suggest that they probably
don't need to make it taller because it
just feels stretched for no really good
reason I like that they've used the
standard search widget here that's great
these these keys here so movies TV
celebs
that again strikes me is a little odd
because they're not really actions so
much as navigation cues so you know as
per sort of the Android standards that
expect them to be over on the left-hand
side over here next to the IMDB logo and
similarly I'll expect this to sort of
behave like a standard action bar I'm
kind of looking for an up caret on the
left here so that I can return to you
know to this to the main page so the
navigation actually works the way it
should but I'm missing some of those
standard cues that I'm really used to
seeing so yeah I'd kind of like to see
these as sort of default regular tabs or
something similar to that you know
rather than sort of being actions when
they're not really actions the general
pattern goes on the action bar on the
left hand side you have the icon
followed by a navigation control and
with everything else like the action
menu items on the right hand side mm-hmm
exactly so things like search they've
got in exactly the right place you know
and having sort of all of this stuff in
the overflow menu again kind of makes
sense I want to highlight as well Thea
that they have the ability to sign in so
you can have an IMDB account and sign in
and presumably things like your watch
lists and ratings history and the
ratings you provide are all been going
to be part of it so what a lot of apps
do wrong is that they don't let you use
anything until you've signed in so when
you sort of install it off Google Play
hit open the first thing you're
presented with in with is this sign-in
screen and that's a real off put it
because if I want not even looked at
this app yet I have no idea what it
wanted and once credentials wants me to
create an account I you know I want to
know what I'm getting into first and so
I love that about this app in that it
lets you experience the food app and
it's not until you want to do something
which requires you deciding that it
actually asks you to do so and obviously
lets you do so as well here in the
overflow menu so that style of
presenting as much as you can and then
having additional features as an
incentive
to actually sign it I think it's a
really good pattern great point let's
have a look so I mean otherwise it's
it's it's you know works pretty much is
it expected to let's have a look at
Total Recall and a movie remake which
fills me with dread I'm a huge fan of
philip k dick and the movie
implementations are usually pretty
questionable Total Recall organism movie
I really enjoyed when I was younger but
I think that maybe the wrong Schwartz
and they can movie but nonetheless um I
always wondered about Schwarzenegger in
though in the lead role of that and you
know Colin Farrell is is a better match
but I don't know I am I'm a prehensile
to say the very least about this remake
in any case you can see here as soon as
we navigate in again we have a wall of
pictures we have a big image of the of
the movie poster we see the top billed
cast all here on the Left we have
galleries and these aren't scrollable so
I guess you have to hit all to see more
of the images so I mean this is kind of
interesting they've got this pop-up
dialog and I hate hate hate pop-up
dialogues particularly when there's no
obvious way to dismiss it and then I
guess that the back button does the job
but I don't know like I feel like this
could be done a little bit neater I'd
like that decision place score here just
like I saw as sorry first inclination on
this section of the screen or so is this
scroll exactly because if they use
marquees elsewhere in the air yeah and
so I'd kind of like to be able to just
flip through here and see see all of the
cast without having to change contexts
the same with the gallery sort of I
click on an image so it actually goes to
the to the to the artist page and
that'll make sense let's check out how
sharing is done in this app okay done
the right way has expired icon screen so
that's that's all nice you know as you
can see like they've really taken this
custom styling to the final degree like
everything is custom these these
dialogues don't look like normal Android
dialogues they're quite tall they've got
the action and not the action bar with
the title bar on top now there's nothing
wrong with customizing the look and feel
of these sorts of things but
particularly dialogues which are general
guidance is to use dialogues
when you're doing sort of a system-level
thing that's when you pop up a dialog
it's like when Wi-Fi is being disabled
or you know if you want user
authentication something which is sort
of more than just the app beyond the
context of the app that's really the
only time you should be using dialogues
and if you're doing that then they
should look like the system dialogue so
that people know what to expect so here
what I would say is you know rather than
saying hey you should be using standard
dialogues which would in fairness look
really weird on top of their custome why
is see if you can get out of using
dialogues at all you know where they're
doing things in place or having a
different fragment switch out some other
way of navigating which doesn't you know
pop something on top of what you're
doing
do you hate dialogues do you hate dogs
as much as I do that it's quite no
notice much I agree with your assessment
in this particular scenario where you
know if it if this implementation wasn't
in place transition would be better you
know it felt like I was focusing on the
right-hand side of the screen and if a
dialog pops up it just breaks the
continuity what about you running yeah a
couple of minutes we've got Manning I
generally agree i generally hate
dialogues I'm more than anything hey
progress and loading dialog oh yeah well
they are of the devil after Chloe in
this case I mean I think dialogue is
really just kind of a shortcut I feel
like in a lot of cases when a developer
you know doesn't really have a great
idea what's the best possible way to
present something a dialog is is a
shortcut and I I've definitely done it
myself I've definitely just said I would
just make it a dialog hmm but definitely
a more a more complete more a better
solution would be just a fragment
lighting in or something of that nature
but yeah it's it's tough to avoid
dialogs always because they're very
tempting but do try to avoid them yeah
that's a really good point I mean
dialogues do represent often a shortcut
it's it's a way of being able to as a
developer when you haven't really
thought through all of the workflows
like well I need to present this
information how can I do that and a
dialogue is the easiest it's like doing
a print line as a debugging snow it's
like a catch are exactly it's like using
a toast to be able to know whether or
not something's happened like we all do
that as part of a development process
like oh this the service has kicked off
so I'm gonna do a toast so I can see
that it's happened and then by the time
you actually go to production hopefully
you've removed all of those you know
there's very few times you actually want
to toast and dialog should be the same
you know that's when you really want to
bring in like a UX UX designer or
someone like that if you can figure out
how that information can be the best
displayed to your users so I think that
pretty much takes us to the to the end
of our a lot of time if we want to give
down Andy and any chance of being able
to prepare in time to it to go on on air
so next week what we've asked you guys
to do is to tell us some podcasting apps
so that's what we're looking for is you
know we all of our we've got all of the
Google i/o sessions have been turned
into a podcast same with all of the
office house shows that we do on
Wednesdays they're all available as
podcasts and really I want to know what
do you guys think are the right apps the
people should be using to consume these
so that's what we're going to be looking
at next week hopefully if you guys
suggest some some podcasting files yet
some indeed a future which I use as well
so well we will be doing podcast a lot
more the other so it's either going to
be the ones that we've heard of and use
or it's going to be the ones that you
guys would like to see is talking about
so tune in for that the other thing that
we have this is a special request as you
can see we have a gun behind us as you
can see it is a gong that has been
optimized for a phone so if anyone out
there has a gong app which looks like a
gun and when you press it sounds like a
gong sounds like a gong we want to hear
about it so there's an opportunity here
to either promote your own app or or
build one specifically for us and it
will be up here on the Friday app clinic
every week so that's the other reminder
as well we are the app clinic now for
those of us who who missed us at the
beginning hence the be white coat we're
really all about trying to look at the
things which apps are doing well things
which apps are doing poorly and try and
help you guys and developers understand
how you can build apps we sure are
really great and provide a magical
experience
so our we're going to sign off and and
we'll see you guys next Friday
thank you guys see you guys
you